he is none other than Trent Dilfer here
on the rich eyes to show how are you
Trent
great thank you no of course so Carla
Murray in Arizona that so everybody just
assumes it's gonna happen because not
only do they share an agent but we know
Kingsbury's loved Murray for a long time
and it's a fit for the offense he wants
to bring the NFL do you agree on all
that front I do I really do I think so
much of this conversation around corvax
every year comes down to set and
sometimes there's just those unique
situations where a coach and a player
philosophy philosophically their systems
everything fit and I think cliff is
gonna have a hard transition into the
NFL in terms of past protection the run
game is going to need a quarterback that
can extend plays that can create space
where they can have some college flare
in the run game while they adapt to kind
of a more hard-nosed NFL style run game
so yeah I think it's perfectly and
that's not an indictment on Josh Rosen I
think Josh Rosen's a starter in this
league for many years but again it this
conversation is always more about fit
than it is talent and that's the lie
that the fan hears all the time is that
talent talent talent when really it's
fit fit fit so in terms of his talent
the fact again that I was at a combine
this year for the first time hearing how
somebody who measures in at five ten and
1/8 checks a pocket a box in a positive
manner Trent do you have any concerns
about him going to the next level at
that height it's a huge conversation as
well as one that needs to be talked
about more I did a couple things this
fall during the season talking about how
for years now we've seen at the
grassroots level changing that what the
modern quarterback looks like what the
modern quarterback throws like what the
modern quarterbacks a pedigree is like
what the modern offenses look like and
what how that relates to how
modern quarterback can thrive and what
we've learned is that the positions
become much less about power and stature
and more about twitch and precision and
I can dive really deep into this or we
can just cover in a surface level but
basically your favorite quarterback
growing up my favorite quarterbacks
growing up it was about Pat power and
stature was how big and physical and
powerful you were cause you played in a
scrum you played in two back sets you
played with an inline tight end you
played with a lot of reduced splits
boxes were heavier and you were throwing
the ball 15 20 yards down the field 15
20 times a game that was the position
over the years the position the scheme's
offense has changed as Moore's there's
been more Saturday influence on Sunday
football now the games become boundary
to boundary it's become wider splits
it's become more spread out it's become
the ball the hand faster it's become
more about decision-making pre-snap
and right as the ball of snap then deep
into the snap as that's happened power
and stature needs decrease and twitch
and precision traits increase so that is
why a 510 and a half-ish quarterback
that has unique twitch who has unique
processing skills can check the box
because now evaluators finally and we've
been saying this for six seven eight
years are finally starting to say well
the games change maybe how we look at
quarterback evaluations she change as
well so if time would call you up or bid
well or even Kingsbury calls you up and
say what should we do what would you do
if you are number one overall right now
like Arizona is going to be would you
take Mari and and send ROS and elsewhere
or would you do something else since you
obviously talked about the past
protection problems and obvious reasons
to so many holes that Arizona needs to
fill what would you try and deal for do
I would take them I think you don't have
something like this fall in your lap
very often if your clip you kind of
realize that you're sitting here
opposite one o'clock in the morning when
everybody's gone home and you're really
being truthful with yourself and you
kind of know you're out over your skis a
little bit in terms of offensive systems
but you do know you're kind of an
innovator you're one of the original
behind the veil air raid guys you also
understand that there's more Saturday
ball coming to Sunday than anybody else
but you need the guy that can kind of do
that for you
and I think in the last five years Tyler
might be the only guy that could do that
he's he's slippery in the pocket he has
world-class twitch he has incredible
precision he will single-handedly be
Superman
sometimes when everybody else is Clark
Kent and because of that reason I don't
see how you don't take him and I think
you know Josh is gonna have great trade
value he's very well received around the
league he's a pure passer he fits other
guys more than Tyler Murray does it's
not that one is better than the other
they just fit different systems and and
Josh fit a lot of the systems in the NFL
well that was gonna be my next question
as so many people are putting him in jag
Rudin's system in Washington that that's
where his most likely spot can be but
then then again maybe the Giants do
something the chargers are being
mentioned even Patriots fans are hoping
that they get him to be the guy after
Brady what do you think is the best fit
for Josh Rosen Trent
honestly thing all those are pretty good
fits this is one of the few times where
the narratives around this time of the
year around the player are probably true
all of those are pretty good fits I
personally would like to see him in
Washington you know I think that with
the circumstances they've had a
quarterback that makes a lot of sense I
think there's maybe a trade back there
with Case Keenum you know there's a lot
of synergies in that deal I think that's
probably the most likely fit I don't
again I'm not behind the closed doors I
don't know what the trade conversations
are like and I have no idea what the
established value for josh is but if
you're the Washington Redskins you're
trying to compete in the division next
year then you need Josh Rose at rental
for Super Bowl champion quarterback head
coach of the elite 11 quarterback camp
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
okay I saw you told Breer at Sports
Illustrated about Dwayne Haskins and
called him Tom Brady ish put a little
bit more meat on that bone Trent what do
you call funny meanwhile I also pulled
over please don't compare him to Tom
Brady those types of qualities you know
if you go and just look at Toms DNA
fierce competitor obviously
perfectionist works as hard as anybody
at the craft of quarterbacking and has
for years has an innate accuracy has
what I call quick a quick switch mind
can process very very quickly about
three pre and post snap has the ability
to spit the ball all over the field any
type of throw euler's throw catalog is
sometimes not talked about enough you
got to have a lot of different throws
your throw catalog has to be expansive
if you're gonna you know fulfill the
fullness of your offense
Dwayne has all those things Dwayne when
we had him in 16 years old act as an
acted as if he was 22 years old he's
mature beyond his years especially in
terms of this football IQ go talk to
Ryan Day and an Urban Meyer about what
they're able to do with him protection
wise very few college teams put
protections on the quarterbacks and if
they do it's like a right-left or one
guy read where he's handling the end
higher protection package at the line of
scrimmage this live area will smoke your
boys it's the ability to do got the
ability to give a quarterback the keys
to the car and make it his offense is
something that's not talked about enough
and Duane has that ability a young age
and you can truly give him the keys to
the car at a young age and your offense
will grow exponentially it won't be
waiting on the quarterback to figure it
out he'll be a head of the office and
when you have that eye and the ability
to locate the ball wherever you want all
over the field with the huge throw
catalog it makes up for his lack of
twitch it makes up for his lack of
movement ability it makes up for his
lack of athleticism because he checks
all those other boxes would you counsel
the Giants to take him at six yes I
think that's logical said I've seen
these mock drafts where he's slipping
down to the Dolphins and and I don't
think that's a terrible fit that might
be better for Duane but I think you're
gonna Giants and I and I'm I'm an Eli
tweener
I can see both sides of the argument but
I think he's a guy who's proven he can
play in cold weather who they can beat
the wind by the rate for which his ball
spins and that's always an issue when
you play in New York and I think he can
handle the bigness of the Big Apple and
I any time a New York team is shocking a
quarterback that's the first thing you
have to look at is can this player
handle the bigness of what he's about to
get into and I think my experience of
Duane and the people he surrounds
himself with I would give a yesterday
well as my next question Trent was about
Eli because again I always defer to you
on subjects like this and Kurt Warner at
wet work when you see the game you see
differently you see what could have been
the throw or what should have been the
throw or what should have been the throw
I had to protect protection held up and
you hear Dave gentleman talk about how
it's a fallacy that Eli's washed what
how much viability does Eli have or
years left with the Giants if they do
not go Haskins six
I think he's a winning quarterback in
the NFL and I don't we could dive deeper
into that but I think he still is a
winning quarterback if you surround him
with enough dudes which they have
especially the rein back position and
you build the offense around his
strength set then I think he's still a
winning quarterback in the NFL I don't
think you can ask him to do things that
aren't in his DNA I think the new system
better fits him I think that with the
runner and the action game he can still
win a lot of games and carry a good deal
of water still immature from Steve Young
I think is a brilliant way of talking
about quarterbacks which is how much
water can you carry I think you can
carry still the majority of the water
for that offense given the supporting
cast and given the type of system
they'll most likely play with sake one
run in the show and certain quarterbacks
again have certain DNA so you can go
back we've done statistical studies of
this and it shows up in stats but also
just a trained eye can see it you can
see when a quarterback is more
comfortable in the action game opposed
to the drop back game you can see you
know quarterbacks more comfortable in
the quick game opposed to the deeper
drop game you know and good coaches
figure that out about the quarterbacks
early on and they build the bulk of the
often surround it Eli's always been a
better extended drop guy so an action
guy you know off play action or a deeper
drop guy where the play can develop we
can rebounder the boundary the more of
that they do the better he'll be the
more you're asking to play with that
I'll use this term for the 400 time in
this interview the marked which you
asked him to play with the more he's
going to struggle so again it comes down
to fit and how the offense is built but
if you do all those things right which
I'm sure that's how the lens they're
looking at it from then you're looking
like oh yeah this guy can win a lot of
games were a few more minutes left with
Trent Dilfer again a head coach Elite 11
and Super Bowl champ in his day so on a
knee again I know that you've said many
times it's about fit not just talent all
that said once Haskins and if we assume
he's second off the board along with
Amari who do you
like from the rest of what could be a
first round graded quarterback in this
draft trend my personal would be Drew
Locke I think he has the highest ceiling
of the rest of the guys I do see some
stuff on film some missed layups that
you get concerned with because the guy
with that type of talent shouldn't be
missing laughs but he's a guy that has
the high high ceiling he's a guy that
developed properly has been through
adversity in college you know this guy
was a power five recruit as a basketball
player so he's got some swag and some
dude in them he knows how to integrate
into a locker room well he does a lot of
different personalities at Missouri
he dealt with you know kind of you know
the student protests on campus and that
dynamic a fired coach a new system so
he's dealt with a lot of stuff and go
watch him you know perform throw a
football get him in a workout and and
he's gonna be pretty impressive I've
known him again
like all of them since they were 16
years old he has what I call DQ's dude
qualities do you have dude qualities it
goes a long ways in a locker room I do
think he probably needs a year under his
belt to me and again I hate trying to
predict what Bill Belichick will do
because I think Gees forgot more
football than all of us to mind but to
me that seems like the heir apparent to
Tom Brady very similar in stature very
similar in arm strength very similar in
the type of game they play I'm not
saying he is Tom Brady but it looks like
that it seems that that's the system
they're gonna continue to run for years
to come you have Tom pie with a year two
maybe three left in them this seems like
the guy that you could take at the end
of the first round that could be the
airport last one for you Trent this
year's draft class and quarterbacks last
year's put them all together
where does tool rank next year for all
that for you number one I he's the
finest prospect I've ever seen in my
life I I was with Aaron Rodgers in
college through through with them in the
offseason not even close to two and
God's
the recruiters know Aaron's progressed
rapidly when he got into the NFL I've
never seen beside Dan Marino and Aaron
Rodgers to this day throw ball better
too
come on he's got all checks all the
other intangible boxes he's got a thick
body you know thick joints I need to
learn to play on time better you know he
does have the Superman complex where he
thinks he can make a Superman play out
every play kinda like an dude and I
think that could be trained out of them
I know we trained it out of him in one
summer but if I was an NFL GM or if I
was a head coach in the NFL I'd be
begging begging on my knees for my
management to draft to or find a way to
drop them I can't say enough things
about he's a space a1 percenter I
obviously know that he's a one-percenter
human being Talent leader anything you
want to say he's a 1% so like Mayfield
Arnold anybody in this year's class did
you didn't stutter it'sit's two in terms
of a prospect in terms of a draftable I
love these guys I've been two years I
think they're all ice cream ice cream is
awesome in general just one flavor of
ice cream you like the most but to it to
me is like the ultimate ice cream on
crack
I guess the greatest it's the greatest
thing you've ever tasted not that I've
done crack but you could ever want and I
know the last visual we all have of two
is playing his worst game of his life
he'd be the first to tell you that I
wouldn't want to play against who this
year Trent you the man always love
chatting with you at Dillards dimes on
Twitter must follow Trent Dilfer on
Instagram you are the man let's chat
again real soon best your family same to
you that's Trent Dilfer
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app